a Texas judge is sharing her story of
survival after she was shot outside her
home a gunmen attacked judge Julie ko
Surak in front of her teenage son Jim
Axelrod reports on her harrowing
experience and the importance of
improving security for all judges in
this week's 48 hours we are never gonna
be the same and we all feel that it
never should have happened
November 6 2015 started as a typical
Texas Friday night for judge Julie
Katherine and her son will we always
went to the football games every Friday
night it was rainy so after halftime we
decided to head home will had his
learner's permit so he drove and as
we're pulling at the driveway
I saw a leaf bag that was blocking the
gate and we thought it was strange I
thought it was a prank and so we will
got out of the car I saw someone start
to kind of walk down the street and then
all the sudden he just started running
straight at me and so I turned around
and ran back to my mom's side of the car
and then he pulled out a gun and started
shooting I think he shot four times
through the driver side window i scooted
down as far as I could in the seat and I
protected my head with my arm in my hand
I can remember thinking I'm going to die
in front of my own son Travis County
9-1-1 is anybody injured my dog and she
told me she was okay and that was a
little shocking at first and then when
she looked up and I saw blood everywhere
I knew that she was not okay the judge
had been shot in her upper body with
unusual bullets that come apart when
they hit flesh the bullets caused
hundreds of gunshot fragments and wounds
well said goodbye to me I told him I
loved him and we just waited for the
police to come it seemed like an
eternity once I heard the sirens coming
I ran down to the street
[Music]
a police arrived and I told one officer
that I was a judge and I felt like it
was related to my work what judge
Kocurek did not know was that a tip had
come into the district attorney's office
saying that someone planned to shoot a
judge information that was not passed on
it was disappointing there were signs in
my neighborhood
had I known in addition that this threat
had come in I would have completely
changed what I was doing and my family
Wow harrowing and Jim Axelrod joins us
now
the judge said right away she thought
the shooting was related to her work yes
did they ever catch the guy yes she but
but it was not anybody who she would
have assumed had targeted her she hadn't
sent this guy to prison she'd put him on
parole and it was for credit card fraud
so it was no one she would have thought
was going to target the other key
dimension why wasn't this tip passed on
well now this is the key to the whole
story and it's something we really get
into tomorrow night so there was an
oversight the Supreme Court justice for
the chief judge of the Texas Supreme
Court said it was a mistake essentially
the DEA the investigator looked into the
case and deemed the threat not credible
so she was never told that there was a
threat and it has changed the way judges
are protected in the state of Texas
because as her recovery she pushed for
judicial reform when it comes last that
9-1-1 call with her son was jailed up
tear a baby survived physically I'd be
curious to see how they're doing
mentally tomorrow night
traumatic Morrow you can't Jim Axelrod
see you at the table you can see Jim's
full report live to tell the vendetta
tomorrow night on 48 hours it airs at
10:00
that is 9:00 Central right here on CBS